Did Newton Really Have an Apple Fall on His
Head?
In grade school you probably learned Newton’s
apple story around the time you learned that
George Washington chopped down a cherry tree,
that people in Columbus’ time thought that
the world was flat, or that the Pilgrims celebrated
the first Thanksgiving in America and invited
the Native Americans to join them.
Since literally none of the latter three stories
here are true (follow the preceding links
for full details), you probably have your
doubts about whether Newton actually sat under
an apple tree and had something of a “eureka”
moment concerning gravity.
It might surprise you to learn, then, that
your teachers got one of these stories (partially)
correct.
Newton was indeed sitting under an apple tree
when he had his so-called “eureka” moment
on how gravity worked.
Although, it took him over two decades more
to develop the fully-fledged theory of “universal
gravitation”, first published in his Philosophiæ
Naturalis Principia Mathematica on July 5,
1687.
He also didn’t complete it without some
ideas others had already come up with, such
as Christopher Wren, Robert Hooke, and Edmond
Halley (who Halley’s comet is named after);
though Newton claims particularly Hooke, who
corresponded heavily with Newton on gravity,
and his ideas had little real bearing on his
work, other than simply to inspire him to
continue working on the problem.
As Newton stated when Hooke accused Newton
of plagiarizing his work:
Yet am I not beholden to him for any light
into that business but only for the diversion
he gave me from my other studies to think
on these things & for his dogmaticalness in
writing as if he had found the motion in the
Ellipsis, which inclined me to try it…
So perhaps “eureka” conveys much too strong
of a leap.
From accounts, he was more just put on the
correct path while musing under the tree.
Further, it would seem that the apple didn’t
fall directly on his head- at least there
is no documented evidence of this.
But if you discount the notion that he near
instantly fleshed out his universal theory
and the “fell on his head” bit, the common
story is pretty accurate.
One of the best sources we have for the “apple
falling on Newton’s head” anecdote is
a manuscript written by Newton’s friend
William Stukeley.
He published Memoirs of Sir Isaac Newton’s
Life in 1752, becoming one of Newton’s first
biographers.
Many of the incidences described in the book
were recorded much earlier than 1752, including
the “apple” story which was first documented
in 1726, the year Newton died, and then again
a year later by Voltaire in his Epic Poetry.
Stukeley’s account is as follows:
After dinner, the weather being warm, we went
into the garden, & drank tea under the shade
of some appletrees, only he, & myself.
amidst other discourse, he told me, he was
just in the same situation, as when formerly,
the notion of gravitation came into his mind.
“Why should that apple always descend perpendicularly
to the ground,” thought he to him self:
occasion’d by the fall of an apple, as he
sat in a contemplative mood: “Why should
it not go sideways, or upwards? but constantly
to the earths centre?
Assuredly, the reason is, that the earth draws
it.
There must be a drawing power in matter.
& the sum of the drawing power in the matter
of the earth must be in the earths centre,
not in any side of the earth.
therefore dos this apple fall perpendicularly,
or toward the centre.
If matter thus draws matter; it must be in
proportion of its quantity.
Therefore the apple draws the earth, as well
as the earth draws the apple.
John Conduitt, Newton’s assistant and the
husband of his niece, told pretty much the
same story.
Newton lived with the pair in his later years
and doted upon their daughter.
When writing about Newton, Conduitt said:
In the year he retired again from Cambridge
on account of the plague to his mother in
Lincolnshire & whilst he was musing in a garden
it came into his thought that the same power
of gravity (which made an apple fall from
the tree to the ground) was not limited to
a certain distance from the earth but must
extend much farther than was usually thought
– Why not as high as the Moon said he to
himself & if so that must influence her motion
& perhaps retain her in her orbit, whereupon
he fell a calculating what would be the effect
of that supposition but being absent from
books & taking the common estimate in use
among Geographers & our sea men before Norwood
had measured the earth, that 60 English miles
were contained in one degree of latitude his
computation did not agree with his Theory
& inclined him then to entertain a notion
that together with the power of gravity there
might be a mixture of that force which the
moon would have if it was carried along in
a vortex, but when the Tract of Picard of
the measure of the earth came out shewing
that a degree was about 69.12 English miles
He began his calculation a new & found it
perfectly agreeable to his Theory.
The “year [Newton] retired again from Cambridge”
was 1666, which means Stukeley’s recording
of the event took place some 60 years after
it happened.
However, both Stukeley and Conduitt, among
others, appear to have independently heard
the story directly from Newton himself, making
it reasonable to believe a falling apple was,
indeed, the source of Newton’s first significant
musings over how gravity works.
There are many different places which claim
to be the home of the apple tree that inspired
Newton’s theory, but the most likely one—given
the accounts—is located at his family home
of Woolsthorpe Manor near Grantham, UK.
And, yes, there is an apple tree there today
that is thought to be the apple tree in question,
though it has re-rooted in the interim after
being knocked over in a storm in 1890.
Now around 400 years old, the tree and the
property are protected by the National Trust.
If you’re curious, the tree is a Flower
of Kent, which doesn’t produce very good
apples for eating by today’s standards,
though they are considered good cooking apples.
Further, the apples in question are green,
not red as is often depicted in Isaac Newton/apple
images.
You’ll note, of course, that Stukeley above
stated there was more than one apple tree
there at the time; so whether this remaining
one is “the” apple tree is a question
can’t be definitively answered until someone
invents a machine that can take us back in
time to observe the event.
That being said, Dr Richard Keesing from the
Department of Physics at the University of
York makes a pretty good case for why it probably
is the correct tree.
Despite this uncertainty, there are a many
trees that have been started as grafts from
the Woolsthorpe tree, including one at Trinity
College in Cambridge which sits beneath the
window of the room Newton used when studying
there.
Bonus Facts:
Astronomer Alexis Clairaut in 1727 commented
on Hooke’s accusations that Newton stole
Hooke’s work, summing up the situation nicely:
“One must not think that this idea … of
Hooke diminishes Newton’s glory… the example
of Hooke [serves] to show what a distance
there is between a truth that is glimpsed
and a truth that is demonstrated.”
Essentially, Hooke guessed at a notion that
Newton was able to prove.
Newton himself never chose to make an official
guess at what actually was the underlying
mechanism of gravity.
In fact, while he noted “It is enough that
gravity does really exist and acts according
to the laws I have explained, and that it
abundantly serves to account for all the motions
of celestial bodies,” he also stated “That
one body may act upon another at a distance
through a vacuum without the mediation of
anything else, by and through which their
action and force may be conveyed from one
another, is to me so great an absurdity that,
I believe, no man who has in philosophic matters
a competent faculty of thinking could ever
fall into it.”
:-)
Besides the above references to who Newton
told the “apple tree” story to, two others
also gave an account of him telling the story
to them: Catherine Barton (his niece) and
Christopher Dawson (a student at Cambridge).
It isn’t clear whether Voltaire heard the
“apple” story from Newton himself or if
he was told it by a mutual friend or found
out about it in some other manner.
That said, the pair were friends or at least
acquaintances, depending on your definition
of “friends”.
Voltaire was even present at Newton’s funeral.
In 1976, Apple Computers briefly used a logo
that featured Sir Isaac Newton sitting beneath
an apple tree.
It was designed by Ronald Wayne, a lesser-known
co-founder of the company.
Apple later changed the logo to the more recognizable
rainbow apple with the bite taken out of it.
Newton has been commemorated in many different
ways.
Perhaps one of the larger monuments to his
genius is a statue by Eduardo Paolozzi which
stands near the British Library in London.
The statue is based on an etching of Newton
by William Blake.
William Stukeley, Newton’s biographer, had
quite the resume himself.
In addition to being a doctor, he had a key
interest in historical monuments and is perhaps
best known for his excavation of Stonehenge.
He was the first person to recognize the alignment
of Stonehenge on solstices and attributed
the iconic landmark to the druids.
He later became a vicar, had a keen interest
in Robin Hood, and wrote music for the flute.
Newton was buried in Westminster Abbey.
Not far down the nave, John Conduitt was also
buried.
According to an inscription, Conduitt “wished
his remains to be placed opposite this spot,
near to the ashes of the great Newton, to
whom he was linked by ties of affinity.”
Mercury was found in Newton’s hair when
it was examined after his death, likely a
result of his experiments in alchemy.
Newton was the second scientist to be knighted,
though it’s thought he was granted knighthood
for political reasons rather than his achievements.
He was knighted in April 1705, over 100 years
after the first knighted scientist, Sir Francis
Bacon, was given the honour in 1603.
The value of “G” in Newton’s famous
“universal gravity” equation wasn’t
accurately determined until 71 years after
Newton’s death and 111 years after he published
the equation.